[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend und
willkommen zum nachrichtenüberblick an
diesem gründonnerstag norbert lehmann
ist auch wieder dabei für den sport und
familie wir haben unter anderem diese
themen für sie
schlag gegen radikale chat gruppe ihre
mitglieder sollen sprengstoffanschläge
geplant haben und die entführung von
gesundheitsminister lauterbach
wer ist die neue familienministerin
die grünen-abgeordnete lisa paus soll
nachfolgerin von anne spiegel werden
und hoffen auf ein jahrhundertspiel
tausende fans von eintracht frankfurt
fiebern in barcelona dem europa league
viertelfinale entgegen
die stromversorgung lahmlegen
gesundheitsminister lauterbach entführen
und dann im allgemeinen chaos die macht
in deutschland übernehmen das war nach
überzeugung der ermittler der plan der
gruppe einer mischung aus querdenkern
impfgegnern und so genannten reichs
bürgern die ermittler kamen ihr zuvor
mit bundesweiten durchsuchungen und vier
festnahmen anna duda und dorothee schmid
haben details
anschläge auf umspannwerke und ein
mehrtägiger stromausfall das sollte zu
bürgerkriegsähnlichen zuständen und
letztlich zum sturz der regierung führen
mitglieder der telegram gruppe vereinte
patrioten sollen den sogenannten pigs
vorbereitet haben auch eine entführung
zählte zu ihren aktionsplan sie trug den
titel klabautermann
hier hinter verbarg sich der plan den
bundesminister der gesundheit professor
dr lauterbach zu entführen und dessen
personenschutz praktisch als
kollateralschaden auszuschalten
bundesgesundheitsminister karl
lauterbach hatte bereits in der
vergangenheit von drohungen gegen ihn
berichtet er sei bestürzt über die
aktuellen ermittlungen hier geht es also
um kräfte die eine also absicht haben
auch den staats- und die demokratie zu
destabilisieren nutzen offenbar die
korona proteste ist eine kleine
minderheit in der gesellschaft aber hoch
gefährlich bei razzien stellten die
ermittler ihnen waffen munition bargeld
und zahlreiche goldbarren sicher vier
personen nahmen sie fest in den chat
gruppen wurde zum umsturz aufgerufen
seit vorbereitet es kann jetzt jeden tag
losgehen nennt es marschbefehl das
system muss weg für unsere kinder für
unsere zukunft wir haben es mit einer
schwerwiegenden
terroristischen anschlags planungen zu
tun wir müssen sagen dass die
entführungs pläne und auch umsturzpläne
eine neue qualität sind insgesamt wird
gegen zwölf personen ermittelt
sie werden der korona protestszene und
der reichs bürgerbewegung zugeordnet
die neue bundesfamilienministerin steht
fest die bisherige anne spiegel war ja
am montag wegen ihres verhaltens während
der flutkatastrophe
zurückgetreten ihr folgt lisa paus
ebenfalls eine grüne ebenfalls aus dem
linken parteiflügel die
53-jährige ist volkswirten seit 2009 im
bundestag und mutter eines sohnes ist
runs stellt sie vor
eine überraschung sie soll
familienministerin werden lisa paus
volkswirtin finanzpolitikerin
bundestagsabgeordnete und politisch klar
links dass die balance zwischen rechtem
und linkem parteiflügel das
entscheidende kriterium war weisen die
vorsitzenden allerdings zurück lisa paus
ist dafür genau die richtige person mit
ihrem sachverstand mit ihren
ökonomischen kenntnissen mit ihrer
erfahrung und mit ihrer leidenschaft für
soziale themen sie brenne für soziale
gerechtigkeit sagt paus erste priorität
eine kindergrundsicherung wir war
kinderarmut immer ein riesen dorn im
auge und jetzt werden wir die
kindergrundsicherung
endlich so gestalten dass sie wirksam
vor armut schützt und ankommt seit 2009
ist die heute 53-jährige im bundestag
mit dem thema familie hatte sie bislang
nur im rahmen von finanzpolitik zu tun
einen namen machte sie sich mit ihrem
kampf gegen steuerbetrug und wirecard u
ausschuss ging sie olaf scholz als
früheren finanzminister scharf an nun
will sie in sein kabinett
gerade in diesen zeiten
bräuchte deutschland eine
führungspersönlichkeit die eben auch
fehler einräumen kann und ich glaube das
ist etwas was olaf scholz nicht gegeben
ist die finanzexperten im haus muss nun
zeigen dass sie ihr wissen von finanzen
und wirtschaft in der familienpolitik
anwenden kann
mangelnde führung das wird dem
bundeskanzler vorgeworfen und zwar nicht
mehr nur aus der opposition sondern auch
aus seiner koalition vor allem wird
scholz aufgefordert der lieferung von
schweren waffen in die ukraine
zuzustimmen die aussenministerin ist
dafür das problem sei im kanzleramt sagt
anton hofreiter gerade aus der ukraine
zurückgekehrter grüner parlamentarier
das buch hat mir die flensburger
fahrzeugbau gmbh hat sich spezialisiert
auf die umrüstung und reparatur von
schwerem gerät auf ihrem hof stehen
unter anderem 100 leopard 1 panzer und
60 panzer moerser all das was die
ukraine gut gebrauchen könnte wenn denn
die bundesregierung entscheiden würde in
einer solchen wirklich schlimmen krise
situation wäre es gut der kanzler
machtvoll er von seinem recht gebrauch
die leitlinie vorzugeben das vermisse
ich und das bedauere ich auch sehr weil
die ukraine kann nicht warten bis
deutschland sich sortiert hat die kritik
an bundeskanzler wächst und sie kommt
von abgeordneten die sich selber vor ort
in der ukraine einen eindruck über die
situation gemacht haben von abgeordneten
aus reihen der koalition
sie haben im grunde große hoffnungen auf
deutschland würden sich wünschen dass
unser kanzler endlich die verantwortung
übernimmt den kanzler eines so großen
und wichtigen gewandes in europa
vor allem die spd ist gespalten vom
mächtigen fraktionsvorsitzenden
mützenich jedenfalls kommen deutlich
vernehmbare bedenken sich vor ort ein
bild zu machen kann richtig sein unter
diesem eindruck allerdings bisher
beispiellose entscheidungen zu fordern
ohne sie selbst verantworten zu müssen
ist falsch zumal diese weitgehende
konsequenzen für die sicherheit unseres
landes und der nato haben könnten die
flensburger firma wurde anfang märz vom
verteidigungsministerium aufgefordert
eine aufstellung zu machen was sie
liefern könnte seitdem haben sie aus
berlin nichts mehr gehört
gunther love energy in berlin wie
gefährlich ist diese führungsdiskussion
für den kanzler und für die koalition
für den kanzler kann das natürlich zum
image problem werden wenn der eindruck
entsteht dass er sich an so
grundsätzlichen debatten nicht
öffentlich beteiligt und schon gar nicht
öffentlich den ton angibt und es ist ja
auch bemerkenswert dass die kritischen
stimmung stimmen an diesem führungsstil
mittlerweile aus allen drei
koalitionsparteien kommen die stimmen
die wir da gehört haben sind auch nicht
irgendwer das sind 3
ausschussvorsitzende im bundestag also
keine politischen leichtgewichte aber
man muss auch dazu sagen innerhalb der
koalition haben sich jetzt schon andere
stimmen zu wort gemeldet die noch mehr
politisches gewicht auf die waage
bringen rolf mützenich den
fraktionsvorsitzenden im bundestag der
spd haben wir gerade eben schon gehört
der hat einen regelrechten schriftlichen
anpfiff erteilt zu diesen forderungen
richtung führungsstil und es hat sich
auch geäußert der parteivorsitzende der
grünen omid nouripour der hat in
richtung anton hofreiter gesagt also
diese kritik am führungsstil das sei
nicht die position von bündnis 90 die
grünen offensichtlich hat er das
führungspersonal der koalitionsparteien
kein interesse daran das ganze zu
koalitionskrach werden zu lassen und
olaf scholz hat übrigens gestern im
inforadio vom rbb schon gesagt zu seinem
führungsstil gerade weil er nicht das
mache was andere von ihm verlangen führe
er doch ist es also nicht zu erwarten
dass er diesen stil jetzt so bald ändern
wird
dankeschön nach berlin für diese
einschätzung von alaba nati
jetzt zum krieg in der ukraine
da gab es für russland einen rückschlag
die moskwa das flaggschiff der
russischen schwarzmeerflotte ist schwer
beschädigt durch einen brand sagen die
russen durch unsere raketen heißt es aus
kiel das ganze geschah vor mario pohl
wie vielerorts im osten bereiten sie
sich hier auf eine russische
großoffensive vor
antworten
sie leisten weiter widerstand
ukrainische soldaten in mario pohl sie
bereiten sich vor auf die wohl
entscheidende schlacht und verteidigen
nur noch trümmer die strategisch
wichtige hafenstadt ist fast komplett
zerstört
ein ähnliches szenario befürchten
militärexperten für weitere städte im
osten des landes hier wird eine
grossoffensive der russischen armee
erwartet diese könnte von lithium
staaten erste ziele wären dann wohl die
städte auf jans und grammaturen die
ukraine geht davon aus dass die
russischen luftangriffe in den kommenden
tagen weiter zunehmen werden um die
großoffensive im osten vorzubereiten
das eigentliche ziel war tatsächlich die
ukraine unter kontrolle zu nehmen sie
politisch zu kontrollieren und letztlich
in zukunft keine unabhängige souveräne
ukraine mehr zu haben sondern letztlich
ein vasallenstaat von russland und
dieses ziel ist jetzt so ein bisschen
zurückgestellt worden russland gibt vor
sich auf dem jaunpass zu konzentrieren
aber wir müssen leider davon ausgehen
dass dieses langfristige ziel nur
zurückgestellt worden ist die ukraine
behauptet sie habe der russischen marine
heute einen schweren verlust beigefügt
und den raketenkreuzer moskwa versenkt
diese satellitenbild zeigt den stolz der
schwarzmeerflotte vor vier tagen in
gewässern vor der krim
der kreuzer moskau wurde von einer chefs
ab der rakete getroffen dann explodierte
munition an bord und das schiff begann
zu sinken
die russische darstellung klingt etwas
anders man habe das feuer gelöscht und
das schiff in einen hafen gebracht sagt
moskau ohne dabei bilder zu liefern die
das belegen
frage nach der von tim kröger wann
erwartet man in der ukraine die
russische offensive
also nach ukrainischen angaben sind die
vorbereitung für eine solche offensive
weitgehend abgeschlossen beispielsweise
die truppenbewegungen oder auch die
verlegung von material also ein solcher
angriff könnte laut ukrainischer seite
unmittelbar bevorstehen präferenzen
lenski spricht davon dass die russische
seite in dieser region zehntausende von
soldaten zusammengezogen hat oder noch
dabei ist hat seine warnung vor einer
solchen offensive in den vergangenen
tagen noch mal massiv intensiviert und
deswegen wird jetzt auch versucht noch
einmal so viele menschen wie möglich aus
diesen potentiellen kampfzonen
herauszuholen sie also zu evakuieren
ukrainische offizielle sprechen davon
dass diese sogenannte schlacht um den
don was an den zweiten weltkrieg
erinnern könnte ganze städte könnten
zerstört werden und die ukrainische
seite hat bereits massive gegenwehr
angekündigt dieser krieg könnte also
jetzt tatsächlich in eine neue phase
eintreten in den kommenden tagen und
wochen in eine phase die noch einmal
brutaler ist als der krieg es bislang
ohnehin schon war
live aus kiew dem krieger vielen dank
bei zdf heute live erzählen zwei
ermittler wie sie in der ukraine beweise
für mutmaßliche kriegsverbrechen sammeln
um 19 uhr 30 in der zdf- heute- app und
auf unseren social media kanälen
73 prozent inflation in deutschland das
bereitet vielen sorge jetzt ist die
europäische zentralbank gefragt
schließlich soll sie für preisstabilität
sorgen durch die ezb entschied heute
erstmal nicht einzugreifen der leitzins
bleibt bei 0 prozent die zentralbanker
fürchten dass höhere zinsen die
konjunktur weiter abwürgen könnten denn
die wirtschaft stehe schon wegen des
ukraine kriegs erheblich unter druck
umweltschützer sehen
hybridautos schon lange als mogelpackung
jetzt will das
bundeswirtschaftsministerium die
kaufprämie für alle plug-in-hybride
schon ende des jahres streichen anders
als im koalitionsvertrag
vereinbart seit juli 2020 gibt es für
autos mit elektro- und verbrennungsmotor
bis zu 4500 euro allein vom staat die
prämie ist umstritten denn die hybride
verbrauchen oft mehr benzin als
angegeben und fahren nur kurze strecken
elektrisch an seinem stern
mehr als 1,1 millionen elektroautos sind
derzeit unterwegs auf deutschen straßen
etwa die hälfte davon so genannte plug
in hybride also die kombination aus
elektro- und
verbrennungsmotor will der
wirtschaftsminister streichen früher als
geplant und anders als im
koalitionsvertrag
festgeschrieben wer finanzielle grund
ist dass wir einen enormen hochlaufen
immobilität haben und nur begrenzte
haushaltsmitteln ich glaube dass die
käufer von plug in hybriden jetzt
sowieso kaufen würden und dann setzen
wir das geld lieber da ein wo noch nicht
das sowieso kaufen stattfindet das wäre
die überlegung dahinter den hinter der
aktion steht sagt robert habeck und
bekommt gegenwind aus der eigenen
koalition aus fdp und spd und aus der
auto-branche die förderung für
plug-in-hybride sind ist ganz zentral
für den einstieg wieder verbrauchen
verbraucher in die e-mobilität hier gibt
es keine reichweiten angst bei
langstreckenfahrten völlig anders sehen
dass umweltverbände überfällig sei der
ausstieg aus der hybrid förderung nach
in hybriden verbinden die nachteile von
verbrennungsmotor und elektroantrieb
es ist in der regel ein schwacher
elektromotor eine kleine batterie und
ein sehr ineffiziente brenner das führt
dazu dass man wenn überhaupt nur kurze
strecken elektrisch fahren kann das
heißt diese fahrzeuge sind wahre
klimakiller
der klima minister plant noch weitere
änderungen die fördergelder vom bund für
reine elektroautos sollen sinken auf
4000 euro im kommenden und 3000 euro in
den folgejahren wird
schauen wir auf die aktuelle corona lage
in deutschland die sieben tage incident
senkt weiter auf 1015 7 dem robert koch
institut wurden 165
1368 neue infektionen innerhalb eines
tages gemeldet und 36.000 weniger als
vor einer woche 310 todesfälle kamen
dazu
größter einzelaktionär ist da schon
jetzt will tesla chef elon musk den
kurznachrichtendienst twitter ganz
kaufen für 43 milliarden dollar die
entscheidende frage ist allerdings ob
genug aktionäre ihre anteile an ihn
verkaufen der milliardär will das
unternehmen von der börse nehmen nur so
könne sich das potenzial von twitter als
plattform für weltweite rede freiheit
entfalten sagt er in den usa sorgt
wieder ein polizeieinsatz für empörung
wieder geht es um die tötung eines
jungen schwarzen durch einen weißen
polizisten die tat ist schon einige tage
her jetzt aber wurde ein video
veröffentlicht und das zeigt wie der
polizist den mann nach einer aus dem
ruder gelaufenen verkehrskontrolle in
den hinterkopf schießt benjamin daniel
berichtet
verkehrskontrolle in grand rapids
michigan die aufnahmen zeigen wie die
polizei am 14 april patrick rioja anhält
weil dessen auto wohl nicht registriert
war plötzlich beginnt der 26-jährige
kongolesische flüchtlinge wegzurennen
als der polizist einen taser einsetzen
will versucht liga in dem beamten
abzunehmen daraufhin zieht der seine
pistole und schießt ihn den kopf
die polizei muss sich nun vor allem der
frage stellen ob der tödliche schuss
gerechtfertigt was wir untersuchen ob
diese anwendung tödlicher gewalt aus der
sicht eines vernünftigen polizisten
nötig war um zu verhindern dass der
beamte selbst verletzt oder getötet wird
nachdem vor knapp zwei jahren ein
polizist in minneapolis den schwarzen
george floyd qualvoll töteten
kommt es in den usa immer wieder zu
großen protesten gegen polizeigewalt und
systemischen rassismus jetzt rückt die
debatte also wieder in den vordergrund
und es sieht so aus als gäbe joe biden
langsam die hoffnung auf dass das gesetz
zur reformierung der polizei durch den
senat kommt so groß der widerstand der
republikaner
der präsident plant nahm einen exekutiv
befehl zu den polizei praktikum wie
dieser aussehen und was er bewirken
könnte wird nun diskutiert genauso wie
mögliche konsequenzen für den polizisten
der zurzeit beurlaubt ist
jetzt
zurück und hibbeligen frankfurt fans in
freistunden beginnt in barcelona das
mögliche jahrhundert im hexenkessel von
carlo gegen barca das
viertelfinal-rückspiel letzte woche
hatte die eintracht ja zu hause ein
bärenstarkes 1 1 erkämpft jetzt wollen
tausende frankfurt fans in barcelona
ihre mannschaft zum sieg tragen
fangesänge auf den ramblas insgesamt
30.000 anhänger
team in die katalanische hauptstadt und
das riesige kam nou stadion gefolgt
steht 1 1 es halbzeit wir gehen jetzt
raus in die zweite halbzeit und unser
ziel ist das spiel zu gewinnen grund für
diesen optimismus ein forscher auftritt
beim 1 1 im hinspiel gegen den
fünfmaligen sieger der königsklasse
barcelona jedoch scheint eine tiefe
krise durchschritten zu haben ist auf
dem weg zu alter klasse für die
katalanen eine pflichtaufgabe für die
eintracht eine art finale an
unterstützung von den tribünen wird es
nicht mangeln heim atmosphäre bei einem
auswärtsspiel
gestern abend feiert liverpool mit
trainer jürgen klopp das weiterkommen in
der champions league nach dem 3 2 1
-sieg in lissabon reichte den reds zu
hause ein 3 3-unentschieden gegen
benfica zweifache fc torschütze roberto
firmino seit dem champions league gewinn
2009 10 steht liverpool erstmals wieder
im halbfinale und trifft auf bayern
bezwinger villarreal ja und auch mancity
und trainer pep guardiola stehen im
halbfinale in reicht da 1 0 zu 0 gegen
atletico madrid ein alles andere als
schönes spiel mit unschönen schluss
sehen atletico philippe flog nach einem
fordern fünf wurden mit gelb-rot vom
platz danach rangeleien zwischen den
spielern auf dem feld ja und danach nach
spielende auch im kabinengang die
polizei musste einschreiten
die deutschen handballer sind mit einem
erfolgserlebnis in die play offs um die
wm-qualifikation gestartet im hinspiel
gegen außenseiter färöer siegte das dhb
team von trainer gislason gestern abend
in kiel mit 34 zu
26 alexanders wäre hat das viertelfinale
beim atp tennisturnier in monte carlo
erreicht der 24 jährige hamburger unten
im bild setzte sich trotz
break-rückstand in beiden sätzen
insgesamt souverän mit 6 2 7 5 gegen den
spanier pablo karen robuster durch im
viertelfinale warten der russe andrej
goworow oder der südtiroler ja nix
mehr dazu dann morgen dankeschön
das osterwetter wird sonnig aber nicht
ganz so warm details hat sich aus dem
tal hier marietta slomka freut sich auf
sie um viertel vor zehn im heute-journal
wir alle danken viel interesse und
wünschen ihnen schöne feiertage bis
morgen wenn sie mögen auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter ruhiges wetter
gibt es über die ostertage denn dieses
hoch über skandinavien rutscht langsam
nach deutschland oder das wetter ist
zweigeteilt nach westen hin ist es
deutlich wärmer hier kommt die wärme aus
dem süden dafür im osten deutlich kühler
die kälte aus dem norden ja und in der
nacht gibt es einzelne schauer nach
osten hin dafür mehr schauer im süden es
lockert auf im westen bei vier bis zehn
grad und morgen laden ganz im osten
relativ dicht bewölkt mit etwas
nieselregen lässt aber nach an den alpen
gibt es schauer das wird auch weniger
sonst zeigt sich immer häufiger von
westen her die sonne bei höchsten
temperaturen von acht bis 13 grad in der
nordosthälfte
13 bis 21 grad in der südwesthälfte die
nächsten tage sind ruhig sonnig und
relativ warmen bei neun bis 18 grad
wobei es im osten kühler ist als im
westen ein schöner abend